[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais je me prépare je vais aux gipsy
tonight le cadet ou la la et ouais je
suis très mince vous savez regardez-moi
ça hein
alors à
quand il n'ya pas de fil c'est rien
c'est mes cheveux y'a rien
[Musique]
non mais maman ta rennes oublier la même
chez palm à ce que le problème c'est les
chaussons maman
d'autres ont pas mes baskets mais ça va
pas ou quoi non qu'est ce qu'on ferait
pas pour notre mère vous remercie
mitchell et
c'est pas drôle
j'avais commandé une voiture électrique
pour l'anniversaire de isaiah et
n'est pas dit que ça arrivera en kit le
cadeau empoisonné
il faut
tout montrer
voilà merci des
[Musique]
demandes mais pourquoi vous mettez pas
trop votre vie privée en story et tout
mais en fait moi je trouve qu'il faut
pas tout partager quoi faut pas tout
dire à demande des gens ont besoin de
savoir qu'est ce que je fais
la journée